[Music]
broke
[__]
okay she left her [__] G with me cuz he
be full of [__] my CL they com with
switch I like they bullly
[__] okay let's go let's go let's
go hey let's break the B out [__] let's
see who really really getting I keep a
bank [__] call me rich rich if I want
rapping right now promised I be 50 Rich
he swear he trapping right now that
little [__] broke his [__] ice creams
on my ni and Rich my ice cream on my
collar the niggaer put [__] for they
put a [__] dollar [__] on the
[__] in the Next Room hear a holler
told that [__] I'm feel a [__] and
[__] your baby father yeah [__] I'm cut
though you ain't got no paper in your
pocket what you sleep girl that [__]
dumb bro rack ass in my pocket got this
[__] from slanging Trap though rack ass
in my pocket got this [__] from slanging
cush bro hey how you say you tra ain't
never having [__] sick of [__] going
broke and start to blame [__] just cuz
you hang with some step don't mean you
stepping [__] most of the rap [__] be
cow watch who you hanging with she left
her [__] G with me cuz bull of [__] I'm
my they come with switch I like they
full of [__] multi rap [__] be they be
bull of [__] I don't [__] with one [__]
who you dealing
with
be
bo hey appreciate you guys watching this
freestyle we got another one coming and
then another one and then another one
and they're all brought to you by our
good Folks at LRG clothing you already
know what it is LRG been keeping you fly
for years they got so much new fly gear
right now
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg when you
check out you'll save 30% off
l-r-g.com another freestyles on the way
presented by LRG